vous voulez des armées la police ou en
tout cas la police qui est au contact de
la population
là encore ça paraît irréaliste
alors que nous sommes en plein état
d'urgence de vouloir désarmer la police
il ya dans nos rues il y a les
militaires de l'opération sentinelles
ouais mais là vous mélangez 2 trucs
parce que l'état d'urgence et la lutte
anti taurins la lutte antiterroriste ça
n'a rien à voir est la police qui
aujourd'hui sévit dans les quartiers
populaires parce que les cartes et vos
biens jusqu'à preuve du contraire c'est
pas c'est pas des terroristes c'est des
jeunes des moins jeunes qui essaient de
vivre
donc il subit sa malice municipaux n'ont
pas municipal bd jean n'est pas pour
l'armement de la police municipale parce
qu'il ya déjà assez d'armes qui
circulent est assez d'armes d'arrêt dans
les mains de la police mais on a bien vu
que les à des cordes policiers qui qui
qui mène une politique de harcèlement de
répression notamment dans les quartiers
populaires
aussi on a vu dans les manifestations ou
là il est quand même pas question de
terrorisme
quand on manifeste contre la vue les
casseurs et le scintillant la colline
rien à voir avec ce que là c'est au nom
du tourisme qu'il faudrait pas désarmer
la police qui ne serait pas armés on
imagine imagine en angleterre il ya des
pays comme ça où le norvège suède des
pays où il ya moins d'armement de la
police et il ya moins de problème donc
ça peut être imaginable aussi mais c'est
surtout cette idée que la répression
c'est pas vrai ça ne sert à rien
contraire c'est contre-productif et plus
on réprime plus on arrête parce que là
quand on voit la ferté au voilà à quoi
sa boutique à l'attitude de la police
ou même la mort d' adama traoré en
juillet dernier un cd cd contrôle de
police qui dérive qui marais et puis ça
finit par un drame ou la mort de
quelqu'un ou le viol d'un autre donc
c'est pour ça que nous ce qu'on discute
c'est qu'il faut bien voir aussi qu'il
ya une société de plus en plus violente
et en plus c'est dans les quartiers où
la vie est la plus dure et la plus
violente parce que la violence arrêté
c'est pas les jeunes des quartiers
c'est la vie qu'on leur impose ses 20%
de chômage c'est c'est un niveau de vie
que les quais hyper bavay pipe idée des
conditions de vie de plus top de plus en
plus déplorables donc si nous ce qu'on
essaie discuter c'est que la solution
elle est sociale cds c'est donner du
boulot c'est développer les services
publics c'est permettre à ce que les
gens vivent dignement sans
discrimination sans racisme parce que
aussi un poème de racisme du côté de la
police on dit pas tout les policiers il
ya quand même
un problème qui est réel donc c'est ça
qu'on essaie de discuter c'est qu'en
fait on est dans une société où on croit
que tout ça c'est naturel il faut plus
d'armes en voie aux états unis ce que ça
donne parce que des armes la police elle
en a tous les américains en ont et c'est
la paix c'est le pays est le plus
violent et le plus de criminalité
donc c'est un peu ça aussi qu'on essaie
discuter sait comment ça peut changer et
7 forcément des discussions sociales des
réponses sociales